a 20 meter ladder is leaning against a
wall
the distance x of t between the bottom
of the ladder and the wall is increasing
at a rate of 3 meters per minute
at a certain instant t sub 0 the top of
the ladder is a distance y of t sub 0 of
15 meters from the ground
what is the rate of change of the angle
theta of t between the ground and the
ladder at that instant
so what i'm going to do is draw this out
and really the first step is to think
about well what equation will be helpful
for us to solve this problem and then we
might just go ahead and actually solve
the problem so 20 meter ladder is
leaning against a wall so let me draw
ourselves a wall here
that is my wall
now let me draw our 20 meter ladder so
maybe it looks something like
that so that is 20
meters
they say the distance x of t between the
bottom of the ladder and the wall so
it's this distance right over here
this is
this distance right over here is x
of t
they say it's increasing at a rate of 3
meters per minute so we know that we
could either say x prime of t which is
the same thing as dx
dt
is equal to 3
meters i'll write it out because it's
hard if i just said m per m it might not
be that clear meters
per minute so they give us that piece of
information so the rate of change of x
with respect to time they give us that
at a certain instant t sub 0 the top of
the ladder is a distance
of 15 meters so the top of the ladder so
let's make this very clear
so
this distance right
over here is y of t
y of t
and they say at time t sub 0 y of t is
15 meters let me just write over here y
of t sub 0
is equal to 15 meters
and so maybe let me write this right
over here this is y of t sub zero let's
just assume that we're drawing it at
that moment t sub zero because i think
that's going to be important
y at t sub zero is equal to 15
meters
so they want to know what is the rate of
change of the angle theta between the
ground and the ladder and this is the
same theta is also going to change with
respect to time it's going to be a
function of time between the ground and
the ladder at that instant so theta
let me get a new color here theta is
this angle right over here this is theta
and it's also going to be a function of
time
so what we'll always want to do in these
related rates problems is we want to set
up an equation and really an algebraic
equation maybe a little bit of
trigonometry involved that relates the
things that we care about and then we're
likely to have to take the derivative of
both sides of that in order to relate
the related rates
so let's see we want to know we want to
know the rate of change of the angle
between the ground and the ladder at
that instant so what we need to figure
out we want to figure out theta
prime
at t sub 0. this is what we want to
figure out
now they've given us some interesting
things they've given us i guess our rate
of change of x with respect to time is
constant at 3 meters per minute
and we know what y is at that moment
so let's see can we create a
relationship
because they gave us dx dt it'll
actually be more useful to find a
relationship between x and theta and
then take the derivative of both sides
and then then use this information
possibly to figure out what the
appropriate value of x or theta is at
that moment so let's do that so how does
x relate to theta
well we use a little bit of a
trigonometry right over here if you took
the hypotenuse times the cosine of theta
you would get x so let me write this
right over here x of t
x of t
is equal to
the hypotenuse
20 meters that's the length of the
ladder times the cosine
cosine
of theta and i could say the cosine of
theta of t just to make it clear that
this is a function of time this comes
straight out of trigonometry
actually our basic trig trigonometric
function definitions
now why is this useful why do i think
this is useful well let's think about
what happens when i take the derivative
of both sides using the chain rule on
the left hand side i am going to have an
x prime of t
and then that's going to be equal to
what do i end up on the right hand side
well using the chain rule first i'll
take the derivative with respect to
theta and so that's just going to be
negative 20
sine
of
theta of t and then i need to multiply
that times theta prime
of t
so what i could do is say hey look at t
sub 0 i know what x prime of t is i
could try to figure out what sine of
theta of t is and then i'll just solve
for this right over there so let's do
that
so at t sub 0 so at
t is equal to t sub 0
what we're going to have x prime of t
well that's at every time it's 3 meters
per minute we'll assume that our rates
are in meters per minute and just our
values are in meters when we're talking
about distance and our angles are in
radians so this is going to be equal to
is equal to
negative
times sine of theta of t
times the derivative of theta with
respect to time so how do we figure out
what sine of theta of t is going to be
well let's just use that other
information they gave us and i'm going
to scroll down a little bit
get a little bit more real estate
so sine of theta let me write it over
here
sine
of theta at time t sub naught that's
what we care about t is equal to t sub
naught what's that going to be well sine
is opposite over hypotenuse so that's
going to be y at t sub naught
over
our hypotenuse of 20 meters
well that's going to be equal to
that's going to be equal to they tell us
y of t sub naught is 15 meters
over 20 meters
which is the same thing as 3 4. so by
this yellow information they actually
told us that this right over here is
going to be equal to 3 4.
so this times 3 4
times the rate of change with of theta
with respect to t
and so now we just solve for this and
we're done so this is going to be what's
negative 20 times 3 4 that is negative
that is
negative 15. if we divide both sides by
negative 15 we get
theta prime of t is equal to
three
over negative fifteen three
over
negative fifteen which is the same thing
as being equal to
negative one
and this the units here would be in
radians per minute because our rates are
all in per minute so if i wanted to i
could write radians
per
minute ideally i would write it right
over here but there you go we were able
to figure out this is an interesting one
because they give you that information
on why but really use that information
of y to figure out what sine of theta of
t is but the equation you set up
involves x and theta